hello everyone and welcome to a couple
of other games that we are going to
check out by way from the Tata Ste
Masters tournament 2024 now we all know
that he already won the tournament and I
I wasn't able to show all of his games
as many many interesting games were
being played every round but now that he
is the winner uh we will check out a few
more so in this video I'm going to show
you his game against Yani pishi his game
from the pan ultimate round against
women's world champion juun and his game
from the tie breaks at the second game
of the semi-finals against Notre backck
satov now for those of you who have been
wondering uh what's been happening with
way well uh seems that he's enrolled in
school he he enrolled in singua
University School of economics and
management supposedly one of the uh best
businesses uh Business Schools in China
and he's been away from chess for well
uh he did play in the in the FED Grand
Prix in 2019 he got eliminated by Yanni
pishi there but his real active year
were where he was sort of active
throughout the entire year was 2017
where he also participated in tata steel
he finished in fifth place and um uh
yeah he also had some some other
tournaments uh he played a super
tournament in danjo in China where where
he finished ahead of I think ding Len
played there vas leuk played there and
he finished a full point ahead of them
so yeah he's been having great results
but uh he took a break for some 5 years
and now he's back and he's definitely
back with Vengeance so let's check out
his game against Yani pishi uh the
person who eliminated him from the 2019
F Grand Prix so let's check it out we
has the white pieces and he opens with
Pawn to E4 if you are interested only in
a particular game I will also have the
the well what the the the time stamps
for the games if you don't want to see
all of them so E4 Neo replies with E5 we
have Bishop to C4 going for The Bishop's
opening Knight to F6 and now Pawn to D3
uh we have Pawn to C6 preparing to
strike with D5 and Knight to F3 we have
Pawn to D5 and Bishop back to B3 we have
Bishop to B4 with check Bishop to D2
blocking and now nipo trades Bishop
captures Knight captures and pawn to A5
preparing to attack the bishop with Pawn
to A4 so way stops him and now Knight B
to D7 we have Castle castles and now
Rook to E1 uh Rook to E8 and now e
captures on D we have C captures and now
there is a game where Knight to F1 was
played but here we have Knight to B1 and
it is now as of move 12 that we have a
completely new game and for those of you
who maybe aren't familiar with this
maybe you weren't really following
what's been happening in chess some five
years ago uh we is the youngest player
ever to achieve the rating of 2700 he
achieved it with um I believe 15 years
of age uh which is I mean uh becoming a
Grandmaster at 15 is very impressive but
becoming 2700 and 15 is well just
something completely else uh but okay
Knight B1 we have Pawn to B6 preparing
to get the bishop into the game Knight
to C3 and Bishop to B7 we have Knight to
B5 now uh eying that D6 Square where you
could attack the rook and the bishop and
queen to B8 stopping that we have Pawn
to D4 and pawn to E4 Knight back to D2
and now Bishop to C6 trying to eliminate
the Knight here the bishop is a nice
piece but with the pawns and light
squares the the Knight um does appear to
be stronger so Nipa wants to trade here
we have C4 Bishop captures and B5 with
have a captures on B5 and now Queen to
F4 neppo brings the queen into the
attack and he's hoping to bring the
other pieces as well maybe you move the
Knight maybe bring the Rook into the
attack uh that's the idea so Pawn to G3
attacking the queen queen to F5 and now
C captures on D5 and the problem here
and well maybe not a problem maybe n
wanted it this way is that you can't
recapture the pawn right away if you
capture with the Knight let's say then
G4 and you cannot keep defending the
Knight that doesn't really matter what
you do if you go here then H4 and the
queen has to leave the defense of the
Knight and instead after G4 if you go
Queen to E6 then just Rook captures um
uh or or even Knight captures on e4 and
you have uh a dead lost position here so
instead after C captures on D5 nippo
brings the other Rook into the game Rook
8 to d8 and now Pawn to F3 uh e captures
we have Queen captures offering a queen
trade and Neo wants to keep the Queens
in the game he plays Queen to G5
objectively trading Queens would be best
here but he did uh crack open the white
King's defenses he wants to go for the
attack we have Knight to C4 by way and
now Pawn to H5 uh going for the pawn
here isn't really possible if you play
something like Queen captures on D5 uh
we would capture on E8 with check
captures trade Queens here and now comes
Knight to D6 with an attack on the
Knight and on the rook and the problem
is if Rook to E6 trying to trade off the
knights uh then comes Knight captures on
F7 so yeah tactically you you get just
demolished here if you captur then
captures and captures uh and if you
don't if you play something like Knight
s to to F6 then just Knight goes back
and okay you're up up a pawn you will
win this game so instead after Knight C4
Pawn to H5 nippo goes for the for for
the white king we have Pawn to D6 and
now uh King to f8 probably H4 is the way
to go but still Way's position is much
better here npple played King to f8 and
it is uh well here that way ye uh made a
beautiful beautiful Rook LIF he played
Rook to E7 uh and there's really not all
that much you can do here if you wait
then you're just going to get um
destroyed here on the F7 square and if
you trade which is what nepo did Rook
captures D captures with check King
captures uh now Rook to E1 with check
more precise is Queen to E2 Queen to E2
check King f8 and now Knight to D6 going
after the F7 Pawn uh instead of what way
e did Rook to A1 with check and after
King to f8 now Knight to D6 because now
there's this annoying Queen to d2 move
by neppo that attacks The Rook here and
uh well uh also uh the the B2 Pawn it's
not um not really the the best situation
here uh so here Queen to C3 was played
you have to defend everything you
defended the rug you defend the pawn and
here nepo just traded off the Queens
Queen captures B captures and now Pawn
to G6 so uh we could have continued
putting on the pressure but uh instead
he he traded off the queens and now uh
well nepo can still defend but it's
still very very hard even with queens of
the board uh you will see just how
deadly uh we is and he just plays the
nice calm Pawn to H3 here there's no
need to rush anything here by capturing
because there's no good Square for black
you can't really uh move the knights
anywhere especially with H3 being played
Knight to G4 is not possible where is
this Knight going also the pawn just
covers that if you play Knight Knight to
B8 then you're going to capture on F7
you don't have to do it before that as
long as your knight is on D6 The Rook
does not have C8 does not have d8
squares and Neo's position is just
terrible he plays Pawn to A4 he tries
sacrificing a pawn to get his Rook
activated but way not interested he just
brings the bishop back Bishop to A2 Pawn
to A3 and now King to G2 we have Rook to
A8 uh try trying something here but now
King to F3 way Reveals His True plans
and that is King F4 King G5 King to H6
uh Rook to A5 uh but just a nice King to
F4 we have Rook back to A8 and King to
G5 not a moveing side for neppo uh Rook
to d8 or or King G7 you know you can
stop King to H6 but then the Rook comes
to E7 and now there's a triple attack on
F7 okay Rook f8 can be played but now
everything is stuck here guarding the F7
pawn and white can do pretty much
whatever uh so instead after King G5
Rook to d8 was played now comes Bishop
captures on F7 it's time to break
through here Knight to B8 attacking the
Knight and now King captures on F6 we
have Rook captures on D6 with check
Bishop to E6 of course you need to block
check Knight to D7 uh also comes with
check King captures and G6 Knight to E5
with check uh trying to get maybe Pawn
captures and then Rook captures or maybe
if the Rook captures maybe you can start
advancing the pawn even though it's not
enough to you know stir anything up uh
King to F6 by we and he was in this
position on move 41 that Yan pishi
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here the problem is now
well you have to move the Knight Knight
to D3 let's say you go after the Rook
Rook A1 and the the pawn will come off
let's say Rook to d8 to Rook captures on
A3 and that's it way he is up two pawns
complete three pawns not too completely
winning and of course nepo uh wants
nothing to do with this position uh time
control has been reached and uh of
course way will win this um easily so
that's what happened in the game against
nepo very nice revenge for that F Grand
Prix loss that nepo delivered at the
2019 F Grand Prix now let's check out
the game against the Women's World
Champion Jun uh uh wayi had the black
pieces here and she opened with Pawn to
D4 we have Pawn to E6 uh Pawn to C4 and
now Pawn to F5 he goes for the classical
ddge defense uh G3 the most popular way
to continue Knight F6 and now Bishop to
G2 we have Pawn to D5 and now Knight to
H3 Knight to F3 is more popular but
still Knight H3 very much played Bishop
to D6 and now both players Castle so
castles castles and uh Pawn to B3 here
uh D captures and C4 we have B captures
on C4 and pawn to C5 E3 guarding the D4
pawn and now Knight to C6 now there are
some games that reach this position E5
is a known move uh but we plays Knight
to C6 and it is now as of move nine that
we have a completely new game so Bishop
to B2 and now Queen to B6 he puts
pressure on the bishop here and just
Queen B3 she offers a queen trade C
captures on D4 we have e captures and
now Knight to A5 attacking the queen
offering a trade and again we have a
queen trade captures captures and The
Rook to C1 and seems like there are no
uh no problems here she she defended
well and uh Wei has nothing to show for
um for his effort but uh that could not
be further from the truth look at this
bishop to D7 okay Knight to D2
developing while defending these pawns
here Rook a to C8 getting more pieces to
attack the pawn and now Bishop to F1 she
adds a Defender we have Rook to C7
preparing to double up on the C file or
maybe even Rook to A8 uh Knight to B3
offering a trade of knights and now Rook
to A8 just asking if you want to capture
on A5 then we can UND double his pawns
F3 and now Knight to C6 we have Pawn to
C5 striking against that Bishop on D6 B
captures on C5 and now Knight captures
on C5 and just Pawn to H6 not allowing
Knight to uh come to G5 Knight captures
and D7 we have Rook captures on D7 and
now she played Knight to F2 here it was
uh crucial to go Pawn to A4 or even uh
Bishop to
B5 uh but in the game Knight to F2 was
played and here we plays this very very
annoying Bishop to A3 move and someone
sorry I just remembered this someone
said in the previous video that Wei uh
in Chinese literally translates the the
playing chess uh amongst other things I
don't know if that's true but if it is
uh I mean
that that's very cool uh so Bishop A3 uh
and now the problem is how do you defend
the pawn here that pawn is just lost
there's no way to defend it if you
capture then just Rook captures and the
the Knight and the Rook are attacking it
you cannot bring more Defenders so Rook
C to B1 was played and now just Bishop
captures Rook captures and Knight
captures on D4 winning a pawn but okay
she will win the B Pawn and then way
will have four against three on the king
side shouldn't be enough for a victory
well that is if you are playing a a
counting pawns game which way most
certainly is not we have Pawn to F4 uh
now comes Rook to A3 just a very active
Rook move Rook a to B1 going after the
B7 Pawn now comes Knight to D5 and okay
Knight to D3 and now Knight to C3
attacking The Rook on B1 uh Rook to A1
and now Pawn to B5 uh we have Knight to
B4 uh and now look at this spectacular
move by we he plays Knight Knight to D1
uh of course the the Knight cannot be
captured otherwise Knight to F3 check
results in Rook captures uh and uh it
it's hard to even make a move here let's
say you play Rook B to B1 now comes
Knight to F3 check King H1 and Rook to
D2 how do you stop Checkmate here uh you
have to play Bishop to G2 and then
Knight to F2 a beautiful double knight
checkmate look at
this uh so not looking not looking good
for Jun she plays rug back to G2 and now
Knight to E3 Again harasses The Rook
here Rook back to B2 and now just Pawn
to G5 he continues marching forward F
captures we have H captures and Bishop
to G2 but now Rook to C7 preparing Rook
to C4 uh we have Rook to E1 and now Rook
to C4 just uh improving the position uh
we have Bishop to B7 uh not a lot of
moves for Jun here King to G7 we have
King to F2 now comes Pawn to F4 gcap
captures on F4 G captures and now uh
Rook to G1 with check but King to F6 and
now there's really nothing more to be
done here Pawn to H4 was played she
started advancing the pawn but here way
just played Rook captures and B4 and he
was in this position and move 39 before
reaching time control that Jew engine
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here year down material
and of course if you captur The Rook
then look at this wonderful checkm Rook
captures on A2 with check King to E1 and
Rook to E2 Checkmate we reach the
position from the thumbnail uh so
beautiful stuff by way uh defeating ju
won in the penultimate round if you
haven't seen the final round game uh way
played against vid garati do check it
out I also have it on my channel it's a
phenomenal game uh he won that
brilliantly and thus qualified for the
tie breaks where in the semi-final of
the tie breaks he faced none other uh
than nck abdos satov and we are now
going to show this game first game ended
in a draw this game Notre backck has the
white pieces and way has black you
you've already seen how he defeated gues
so you know that he won this game now
it's mely a matter of how he won this
game so let's check it out Norbeck plays
Pawn to E4 we have Knight to F6 look at
this the madman going for alin's defense
in a in a sort of okay it's not a
must-win situation you can also get a
draw and then uh push further tie breaks
but still Knight to F6 uh incredible
Pawn to E5 Knight to D5 D4 uh and now
Pawn to D6 we have Knight to F3 and now
D captures on E5 Knight captures and
pawn to C6 so a very very solid approach
uh Bishop to D3 we have Knight to D7 and
now Knight captures on D7 Bishop
captures and now Castle so all been
played before nothing new here we
prepares to F to his dark Square Bishop
Rook to E1 and now Bishop to G7 Pawn to
C3 castles and now Knight to D2 We have
Rook to C8 and here there are a couple
of games where Knight to F3 was played
but here we have Knight to E4 and it is
now as of move 12 that we have a
completely new game uh Rook to E8 of
course you want to advance that pawn uh
Bishop to G5 now stopping the
advancement of the pawn we have H6
Bishop back to D2 and now Pawn to B6 so
really really slow playing this we have
Queen to C1 putting pressure on that H6
Pawn King to H7 defending Now Pawn to H4
Notre Beck's pieces are excellently
placed here he has the Knight here the
two Bishops the queen the pawn is coming
to H5 he wants to go after Way's King we
have Pawn to F5 chasing away the Knight
Knight G3 and now Pawn to E5 finally
striking in the center Pawn to H5 way he
uh responds by striking on the king side
and pawn to
E4 uh we have H captures on G6 with
check but just King captures and here uh
Bishop to E2 trying to get that Bishop
to H5 check in to pick up the Rook here
so just King back to H7 and now Knight
to H5 so okay another did bust open uh
the the black King's defenses but this
also does give way the semiopen G file
uh to use for his Rooks and that he goes
for Rook to G8 and here uh we have Pawn
to C4 attacking the Knight and um uh
this uh well as I'm showing you three
games in this video I I I thought about
it very hard which moment I should use
for pause the video uh and this is the
moment that I have chosen and uh in the
game way did not find the correct
continuation but uh you guys have time
you're comfortable in your own homes
feel free to pause the video and try to
find the absolute best move for we here
while I give you a couple of
seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on
sporting this incredible maneuver and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show it is Bishop capton D4 that's
the stuff you you could also start with
Queen to H4 but Bishop captures on D4 is
more precise and you will play Queen to
H4 uh so so it does really matter now
the idea is that after C captures on D5
you don't have to worry about this
Knight now you play Queen to H4
threatening the F2 pawn and after Rook
to F1 there's Rook captures on G2 uh
with check so this is only one of the
lines but all of the lines are winning
and now okay you can't give a check yet
because the Knight goes to G3 but you
stop it pawn to F4 first and if white
captures an F4 now you play Bishop to H3
with check King to G1 and now Rook to G8
with check Knight to G3 but it doesn't
matter Rook captures Bishop captures and
of course Queen captures on G3 the F
Pawn is pinned King H1 and queen to G2
will be Checkmate so uh such a maneuver
was in the position but Notre Beck
pushed the pawn strong he scared we and
we moved back with the Knight Knight to
C7 and now notbe eliminates the Knight
the bishop on G7 Rook captures and the
bishop captures on H H6 but okay Rook to
G6 not backck is up a pawn uh but this
game is not about counting pawns uh we
have Bishop to F4 uh and now Knight to
E6 and now give me just a second I have
to change the letter on the little robot
uh just so you guys don't think this is
a classical game of course this is a
Blitz game as these are Blitz tiebreaks
uh so I don't want to uh trick you guys
there we have
it all right
sorry about that uh and queen to E3 and
now uh well there's still work to be
done here but both players have a
playable position here and uh while you
could capture on F4 Queen to H4 way he
brings the queen into the attack and he
keeps material on the board Queen G3 uh
Queen back to F6 and now Bishop to E5 we
have Queen to H4 and G3 now now Notre
backck is considering King to G2
followed by Rook to H1 check so of
course Queen to H3 and now Bishop to F1
chasing away the queen queen H5 and now
Queen to E2 offering a queen trade and
queen to H6 we have Bishop to G2 and now
Rook C to G8 so bringing everything over
to the king side uh where he wants to
attack but it's not easy as not's Bishop
is doing an incredible job at defending
this position we have Pawn to D5
striking in the center Knight to G5 with
we have Bishop to F4 now not allowing
the Knight to move but that's exactly
what way he does Knight take H3 check
and now you have to capture the Knight
otherwise Knight captures and F4 will be
winning so captures captures and now
Rook a to D1 uh very very uh calmly
played Rook to G4 now threatening Rook
captures on F4 as the G Pawn is pinned
uh Queen to F1 offering a queen trade
Queen to H5 and now you have to repeat
with Queen to E2 it's the only way to
continue Queen to E2 and you don't have
to worry about captures because there's
Queen captures with check however Bishop
to C7 was played uh Notre backck says uh
well there there's nothing for you to do
here I will play King G2 and then maybe
Queen to H1 or I will now play Queen to
E2 uh or I will just capture and you
know win the D5 for myself but now the
position is completely winning as F4 uh
seals the deal now you you are not in
time if you play something like King to
G2 then just Rook captures on G3 with
check F captures Rook captures and G3
and that's it King F2 Queen to F3 will
be Checkmate so in instead Rook captures
on e4 was played at least uh once way he
captures you will be able to capture The
Rook here but even that is not possible
F captures on G3 by way and now if you
capture The Rook you get checkmated
Queen to H2 is Checkmate so Rook to E7
with check and now King to H6 F captures
on G3 uh but yeah the bishop here is
guarding the G3 Pawn but only once and
you are attacking it twice so Rook
captures on G3 way he sacrifices The
Exchange Rook captures on G3 with check
King to F2 and now Rook to F3 with check
doesn't matter where you going as The
Queen Is Lost and it was in this
position on move 43 that Notre be aatro
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here once the king moves
the problem is you play Rook captures on
F1 with check and if King captures you
pick up the Rook on D1 and if the Rook
captures of course Queen to G5 check
eliminates The Rook on E7 and that's
pretty much it you have zero
compensation for the queen so of course
this pointless to continue uh so after R
F3 check notbe resigned you know what
happened way went onto the finals to
face GES uh in in the tie breaks of the
Tata still Masters 2024 and he defeated
him if you haven't seen it also do check
out that game you have it available on
my channel and um yeah brilliant stuff
by we I know some of you said that you
would like to see more games so I showed
you the ones that I thought were were
the most interesting and the ones that
we missed uh but yeah also in the
description of this video you will have
uh way e IM mortal game if you haven't
seen it do check it out it's really
really wonderful I think it's from 2015
um against uh Lazaro Batista Bron uh so
do check it out it's an incredible game
but you know it's only six minute long
video it was uh some six years ago that
I've made it so maybe it's even time to
remake that video if you would like to
see a remake of that video with more
lines with uh you know more action also
comment on that and also I will include
his game against louing from last year's
champ his chess League that he played
considered sort of a wayes second
Immortal or wees mini Immortal so do
check out that one as well the two links
in the description below uh you know not
a bad way to spend the day uh so that's
the game or those were the games hope
you guys enjoyed that uh for those of
you who haven't seen the standings these
are the standings uh before before the
ti breaks okay it says Notre is first
but basically we have four people on
eight and a half Notre on and we
they went into tie breaks and way
emerged Victorious we have on seven and
a half points vit pranda and
ala fuja and six and a half Yanni pishi
world champion ding Lan on Six Points so
even below 50% that is absolutely
amazing uh Jordan F Forest Alexander
donchenko param mulu and ju Wun on four
and a half and Max vam uh who had a uh
great start to the tournament but uh he
lost his last five games uh so that's uh
you know pretty pretty crushing and also
here are the results of the final round
if you haven't seen it dingler drew his
game to women's world champion jujun
parhan lost to GES Wei defeated vidit
Norbeck defeated Alexander renko Anish
defeated Max faram prag and ala Drew
their game Prague pushed for a win for a
very very long time but in the end alza
was precise and was able to defend and
nepo and Jordan Drew their game I don't
think either of them were really
interested in playing as they're not
very very very happy with their
tournament uh so yeah that's a little
bit of info about the event if you guys
have some games that you would like
shown do use hasht suggestion also if
you have some favorites from The
Challengers section also use hashtag
suggestion but until then check out the
two games in the description below
really really nice chess being played
there uh so yeah I hope you enjoyed it I
would like to thank ala simu play Samuel
Kane Gerard hlan Jeremy antios and David
gasparian for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you all
for watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World and I will be continuing
my rapid action unleashes uh so you know
there's also that uh so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day